push jumper fell
shot in the back of the head dragging
yourself away I got that's awful
Vehicles registered to Maggie Moore
you say Maggie Moore
two Dead Maggie Moore was one week apart
yeah that's weird
Mr Moore can I help you I'm looking for
Jay Moore he's not here they're
separated oh big fight you need to leave
oh I need to leave this is my house
Maggie
she did yell the word filth I caught
that well Jay Moore's into something
my wife is threatening to go to the cops
I would like you to scare her off the
idea
[Music]
they're gonna nailed me for this you
understand
loyalty member oh I see there's two
Maggie Moore's in the system what are
the odds of that
is Maggie won mistake for Maggie two
where's Maggie two to cover for Maggie
one
if we remove the second Maggie more
it'll make it look like my Maggie was
just a mistake you gotta make it look
like it was an accident and I'm off the
hook
I pretty clearly said scare her not set
her on fire somebody out there that's
really good at what they're doing she
looks like he's been shoved around a
little bit Junior detective who would do
this we'll find out sooner or later we
always do this nutcase is setting me up
uh that's crazy false she just dropped a
dime on Maggie's husband life insurance
700 okay
thank you
that ties it all up in a nice little bow
doesn't it give me some backup now wash
your car wash your ass oh we do it you
seem really what's up over this hey the
way there's more Maggie Moore Maggie
more Maggie more Maggie more